hello everyone and welcome back to some
current events uh we're gonna be
checking out on what's been happening in
the chess world while we were busy
covering the the morphe saga uh this is
a game from the singing field cup and uh
already five rounds was over played by
this is a game from round four it
features jeffrey xiong and fabiano
caruana and fab is kind of a legend when
it comes to the seeing field cup as he
won the 2014 six field cup with
just an unrivaled performance he uh
crashed the tournament which had an
average elo rating of over 2800 and he
had an uh rating performance of over
3100 so that's extremely impressive and
the tournament featured the extremely
strong players magnus played lavon
played he car played the paul played uh
and mvl and uh
to this day i think that's unrivaled
considering the sinful cup and uh i i
think it's even you know okay if we
maybe if we uh disregard uh maybe
fischer's rating performance when we
take into account everything that he
achieved from you know starting the the
palm of the american terzonal to the
candidate uh matches to his uh match
with posky uh i think this would be uh
maybe the the best rating performance
but all in all uh you know fabia a
pretty pretty uh big legend uh in the
sink field cup uh here he faces jeffrey
xiong and it's quite an interesting game
so let's check it out as this is the
first game we're showing from the
tournament it's a classical tournament
uh and of course i forgot to
replace the little e so just give me a
second there
there we go nicely done
all right a few more seconds
uh so yeah this is a classical
tournament 19 minute 90 minutes per
player for the first 40 moves and then
for the rest of the game you get you get
an additional 30 moves it's a 10 player
classical round robin event of course
taking place in st louis uh and the
price fund is 1.275 million dollars so
that's that's a lot of money now getting
to the game let's check it out chiang
with the white pieces opens with knight
to f3 so he goes for the red opening uh
we have d5 by fabi g3 and now c5 your
opponent is you know developing on the
flank of course you will grab the center
uh we have bishop to g2 and now e6 and
now xium just castles fabi goes knight
to f6 and now striking in the center
with the d4 and here uh usually you go
knight to the c6 or capture on the four
five you played uh pawn catchers on d4
uh knight captures on d4 and now e5
grabbing the center uh even more as now
uh these pawns are really really strong
knight to b3 and now uh a fabi goes for
a5 and now uh you you could also play
bishop to e6 here it is the the mostly
played move here but favi plays a5 and
it's been played only once
uh up until this point and uh in the
game that we're talking about uh it was
uh countered by a4 it was the game oleg
roman initial versus bruno bellotti uh
where roman engine won that game very
nicely uh but xiong doesn't care about
the a4 the a pawn instead of a4 he just
uh
well continues uh with uh
uh bishop to g5 so he just continues
development and it is now already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game uh fabi now takes this opportunity
to kick away the knight from this square
we have knight back to c1 and now we
reach the position from the thumbnail
you can see that um it's not very often
you will see the knights on b1 and c1 so
i thought it was a funny position white
having knights on b1 and c1 and black
having this massive center here
but okay uh favi continues development
we have bishop to e6 and now you could
continue for example knight c3 to add
more pressure to the pawn you could play
c4 attack the center with a with a c
pawn but xiong goes for e4 this
basically calls for a d for advancement
by fabi which he does uh and now comes
f4 we've made him or maybe over commit a
little bit in the center and now we're
gonna undermine his pawn center and fabi
has to figure out how to deal with this
if you if you allow f captures on e5
while your knight is spinning that's
going to end really badly so you could
go for knight to c6 for example uh but
fabi just plays bishop to e7 and the
idea is that if xiong wants to grab some
pawns uh he's more than welcome to do
this but fab is going to play knight to
g4 and after let's say a trade here
captures captures he can grab yet
another pawn uh but now black simply has
so much for for the price of these two
pawns let's say knight to c6 the queen
can move and even if queen to d6 trying
to trade queens queen to g5 for example
and now black will be down two pawns but
he uh he's up by a lot in development
white has a doubled pawn here he's
hemming in his own light square bishop
so black is to be preferred here
uh so instead after this bishop to e7
idea by fabi xiong just continues
development he plays knight to d3 and
okay fabio also continues development
knight to c6 and now
again uh capturing here just knight g4
and the white is not really having a
good time having these double pawns here
so instead we have bishop to f3 later on
the bishop can come to h5 which will be
very useful uh knight to d7 by fabi
offering a trade of dark square bishops
and shion characters we have captures
captures and now knight to d2 and the
knights to d2 is a very tricky move
because it takes away the c4 square from
fabi's bishop so is fabi if fabi is
reckless here for example he castles f5
and we trap his bishop so we can't
really allow that so after knight to d2
we have b5 now fabi is uh freeing up the
c4 square for his bishop the pawn is now
nicely defending this
and now comes a b3 again guarding the c4
square
and fabi has to do something about this
he plays f6 he frees up the f7 square
for his bishop uh bishop to h5 with
check and now fabi blocks it we have g6
but now the bishop doesn't go back but
rather we have f5 by xiong uh we have
bishop to f7 getting the bishop out of
harms away and now captures captures and
the bishop goes back bishop to g for so
who profited for this uh from this was
it white or maybe fabio he now has the
open h file for his rook uh and he it
does seem that his bishop has a lot more
squares to use now so maybe maybe black
really didn't mind this idea from white
and phobia says all right your bishop is
a lot more active mine isn't doing all
that much let's just trade it so bishop
captures an e6 we have queen captures on
e6 and now knight to f3 uh pretty much
stopping any idea black might have had
of playing f5 because uh well you just
weaken the e5 pawn too much then both of
the knights will be attacking e5 queen
is coming to e2 will attack e5 duro can
come from a1 to e1 will also join the
attack to the e5 pawn so this spawn on
f6 is doing a fine job so here fabi
played g5 and now comes queen to e2
white connects the rooks here and now
fabi has to decide how to
uh treat this position and it's not
an easy decision because it's it's a
pretty wild one and you could do a lot
of things uh
for example king to f7 connects the
rooks uh gets the king to to the king
side you might also consider king the d8
the c7 you connect the rooks this way
but then bring the king over to the
queen side but fabi tried knight to d8
he wants to bring the knight over to f7
uh but this allows a white uh something
that uh well whenever i see this i
remember
josh wadeskin's advice from the chess
master uh 9000 i believe it was series
uh he said always look for the square
left behind and here by playing knight
to d8 fabi left the b4 square uh this is
the square left behind and xiong
immediately jumps uh
well jumps to this square we have knight
to b4 and now the knight will be able to
jump to d5 so that's a
really a great square for this knight
and it will not be easy to get rid of it
uh as you'll see in the game so the pawn
is also being attacked here by the queen
we have rook to b8 defending the pawn
and not knight to d5 so this is not a
beautifully placed knight and maybe it
could have been averted but i don't
think fabi uh found any any active plans
the the the the the ones that we mention
king to f7 or maybe just bringing the
king to c7 uh do do feel like uh maybe
um a bit of a too passive of a plan uh
give just give me a second i think maybe
meadow is is joining us
yes it was meadow
sometimes he just you know pops up uh so
after knight to d5 uh black has to
decide what to play here and fabi just
castled here so we have castles and now
uh what does xiong play well he has a
beautiful place tonight his rooks are
connected the knight is nicely placed on
f3 so now it's time to bust open the
position and he starts with h4 now
there's a question uh maybe uh h4 is a
bit premature because you want to play
rook f2 and rook a to f1 at some point
so maybe maybe you could do it now or
maybe you want to bust open with h4
first
i guess it's a it's a matter of
preference so here we have h4 uh and now
you don't want to capture this if you
capture this allow knight captures then
you gain full control of the f5 square
then you allow queen to g4 and black is
just getting destroyed here so instead
after h4 we have knight to f7 by fabi
this is the idea behind knight to d8 uh
and now h captures on g5 again rook f2
rook 8 to f1
is always possible but xiang decides to
capture first we have f captures on g5
and only now rook to f2 is the doubling
on the f file happening uh we have
knight to b6 here
again a very very tricky position you
could dislodge this knight with g4 but
then you allow knight to h4 to f5 on the
other hand there really isn't an active
move here for for for fabi to play
because it's such a such an ugly
position to have so fabit tries knight
to b6 but this also means that yes while
he's getting rid of this monster knight
on d5 he's allowing queen captures on b5
and shiongu goes for it we have queen
captures and b5 knight captures on d5
and now as the rook is attacking the
queen you have to recapture this so you
could capture with the pawn okay and
then maybe capture here uh which
doesn't seem like a bad idea for example
pawn captures rook captures here the
captures on e6 uh also seems very much
uh very much playable but for some
reason xiung disagrees with it he plays
queen captures on d5 fabi uh captures
and now he captures on d5 and now he
wants to get rid of this one pawn on the
queen side a captures on b3 a captures
and now fabi plays uh d3 and d3 is
already
a very tricky move but there was a maybe
a simpler way of you know just calming
things down for example rook to b5 you
go after this spawn and the question is
can you defend against rook to a6 and
the rook coming to g6 and all the
threads that follow the question is yes
most likely uh for example rook captures
on the e5 and now after rook to g6 check
king to h7 now we're going to play rook
to f6 and it seems like we're
threatening a lot of very nasty stuff
but king g7 here and it seems that uh
you're controlling everything very
nicely uh not
a lot to to look forward to uh the
problem is if you go knight captures on
g5 here uh it's not a problem because we
can capture here and after rook captures
on f8 now we have this knight to h3
check and we're gonna win back our uh
our material king g2 knight captures an
f2 and now the rook of course captures
back and yes you're down upon but you
will be able to draw this so what you
would probably have to do after king g7
is not go for knight captures on g5
probably knight to d2
but still it should should not be a
problem uh black has everything under
control here black can simply play d3
now the move that he played earlier and
if c3 for example rook here and now you
have this position where white has a
path b and c pawn black has a past d and
e pawn and it's a complete mess of a
position but you know probably black
black will hold but white has an easier
time playing this position
but fabi instead tried d3 and now okay
we have c captures on b3 rook captures
on b3 and now rook to a6 so a very
similar position but also a different
one
and here uh fabich fabi should just
continue grabbing with the rook captures
on d3 and now the the the idea is pretty
much the same if rook g6 king h7 rook to
f6 uh
it seems like white is making progress
but we have this e4 move and this is the
one that was really really hard to the
spot now the thing is uh after knight
captures on g5 and knight captures rook
captures and f8 uh of course again
knight to h3 saves the day king f1
knight captures we're gonna play king
characters because our rook is no longer
attacked but now rook captures on d5 and
it's a dead draw
but instead after rook to a65 he did not
go for rook captures on d3 five we tried
rook to d8 now going after the d5 pawn
as well
but the position is now
actually lost for black so feel free to
pause the video here and to win the game
for xiong while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing it's
the exact idea we've already shown twice
only the difference is this time it
works so congratulations to everyone who
found it and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's rook the g6
with check and now of course you can't
go to the f file because our rook is
there just moving the knight anywhere
just wins the game for us so we have to
play king to h7 and now rook to f6 and
here there is no move that fabi can play
because your knight is attacked and you
can't move it and you can defend it so
we're going to show three really fun
lines that uh well it just nicely
illustrates why this is so so if you
move the ninth knight to d6 the problem
is knight captures on g5 the black
knight no longer guards the
g5 square so knight captures on g5 you
have to move the king king g7 now knight
e6 check king h7 and you are getting
checkmated rook h2 check king to g8
we're gonna play rook g6 check king f7
rook to g7 check we're going to play
king f6 rook to h6 king f5 and now the
beautiful g4 to end the game the rogue
g5 is also winning but g4 i i always
think it's much nicer to you know
mate to the opponent with a pawn uh or
at least with a piece with uh of the of
the least
cost so here after rook to f6 you can't
really move the knight if you try
defending the knight it's not really
much better we're just gonna capture the
knight here and after rook captures now
knight captures on g5 and now we attack
both the rook and the king and also our
rook is
already attacking the rocking g7 we're
gonna capture the rook and we're up a
full piece of course completely winning
and another thing after rook to f6 since
we can't move the knight we can defend
it with the rook maybe we can defend it
with the king now there's no check here
but the problem is there is a check rook
captures on f7 king captures and now we
are under the mask of the rook knight to
d for check or d2 we could choose the d4
or d2 i prefer d4 since it's you know
looks
cooler as the pawn is kind of attacking
the knight but then after the king moves
we're going to capture the rook and
we're again up a full piece so it didn't
work the first two times but this time
rook g6 uh rook g6 to f6 works and
there's really no move fabi can make
here so so fabi simply captured the pawn
here on d3 and he was in this position
on move 36 that fabiano caruana resigned
to the game
and a very nice victory by jeffrey xiong
against the legend of the singfield cup
of fabiano caruana
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it like i said i haven't really been uh
following what's been happening in the
chess world while we were covering the
morphy saga so if you have any of your
favorites any of your games that you
would like me to show use hashtag
suggestion or send me an email or
something i will review the game uh and
you know if it's a fun one we're
definitely going to show it but for now
i'm probably going to be uh covering the
some of the
interesting games for from the sinful
cup uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank harry
barton tom derelo balashtanka david
kimura and jay langdon consulting for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
simple cup and whatever else is
happening in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day